the Internet of Things is an idea that's
been around for I don't know maybe 10 15
years or so and I think the first time I
heard about it there was some discussion
of a European appliance manufacturer who
had a refrigerator that was connected to
the network the the Internet and I think
the the scenarios that were playing out
there were ok what if the refrigerator
was smart and knew that that was new
enough to adjust temperatures maybe it
knew enough to to send a request or a
message to the manufacturer saying hey
the compressors going bad that was kind
of the first time I had heard about this
idea of connecting a product to the
network a product that wasn't a
traditional computer wasn't something
that we thought was supposed to be
connected to the network or
interconnected and that started to open
up a lot of people's eyes I think to to
this idea it may not have been the first
theoretical time that it was discussed
but it was the first time that I think
popular media and culture started
talking about this idea but for whatever
reason that connected refrigerator
really didn't take off the idea really
didn't kind of explode I think then we
started hearing about the connected
washing machine in the same kind of
context and I think that that idea of
the Internet of Things then started to
refine a bit and we heard about machine
to machine communication the idea that
instead of human to machine so sort of
through a screen or through a web page
or through our mobile phones or whatever
that machines would talk to one another
and so the idea of a stock quote
generating a message that would be sent
to another machine that might think
about ok now I may need to make a trade
so the automated trading world or a
weather forecast that's reported online
triggering a message to another system
that's going to adjust stock levels so
this idea that machines might talk to
one another without a human in between
was sort of a refinement I think of the
Internet of Things idea and now over
last handful of years we're seeing more
consumer facing ideas and concepts and
products coming out that I think has
regenerated interest in this in this
machine to machine communication so now
we're hearing things about the connected
car and the connected thermostat in the
smart home and so now that the the
consumer side of things is is heating up
we're also asking ourselves from a
business perspective what is the
Internet of Things for a business maybe
where you don't have a consumer product
or a thing a widget that you sell maybe
you're a services company or a bank what
is the Internet of Things mean for a
business like that a particularly a
services company and so for for
companies that aren't as a consumer
facing or product oriented I think you
know there there's more opportunity but
more sort of clouds around what that
what the Internet of Things means for
business and I think that anything that
we that we think about that we estimate
that we operate in that the places we
work in people we work with we think
about the effectiveness of those things
the effectiveness of our workplace the
effectiveness of a warehouse the
effectiveness of routes that a truck
takes or that a forklift makes and we
make guesses about the right ways to to
design a workspace or design a logistics
path design a warehouse and the question
is can we use the idea of sensors to
collect data about things that we were
just guessing about before that we were
estimating that we were that we were
sort of like using our gut to design can
we collect real data about performance
of people and places and processes that
can give us more insight into optimizing
and evolving our designs for the way our
business works and that's what I call
the internet of business things it's not
the consumer-facing stuff it's the
business stuff most of the data we think
about from a an enterprise perspective
is is sort of modular its transactional
its
it's a call center call or it's a web
transaction or it's a sale or it's a
quote or it's a piece of data about a
product but the Internet of Things will
be creating streams of data so one of
the analogies is is how social media
creates streams of data so we've got
tweets and we've got flows on our on our
wall and such that are more streams of
information and so think about a sensor
that might be on a door in a warehouse
every time the door opens the sensor
records a door opening a time of day a
day of week maybe it creates some other
ambient information like it records the
temperature in the in the facility or it
records how long the door was open or
whatever so these are little bits of
data that are happening every time the
door is open and that door might be open
a lot of times during an hour or a day
or a week or a month but it's creating
these streams of data and it's it's not
like that one piece of data might be
that interesting but it's the trends and
the patterns and things that we're
looking for in the data that may be what
we're looking for so I want to know you
know how often is that room used during
the morning the afternoon certain days
of the week weeks of the month that you
know months of the year to help me be
more efficient about the way I staff
people in that office or the temperature
or the cooling or the electricity that I
feed to that part of my of my facility
so that data that's created these
streams of data are sets of data that I
may not already have a technology
platform to process I don't know how to
process streams maybe so now I have to
think about a new architecture a new way
to process a stream of data not just a
stream but you know maybe I have a
hundred facilities that I have these
sensors in and they're creating these
streams of data so now I've got a new
challenge around data one of the
challenges starts to feed and link into
the big data topic
so as I'm collecting these individual
sensor data points over hundreds or
thousands or tens of thousands of
sensors every minute or every second
I've now got these these the
parallel streams of data I have to
process and so it's unclear exactly how
much data I would want to keep for how
long but it's certainly a new kind of
data architecture and for some companies
will be a big data problem because
there's going to be a lot of this data
for large companies for a lot of sensors
and a lot of facilities or a lot of
products that they want to track or
whatever it is that they want to get
more insight into by putting tags or
sensors on them so to me this is one of
the sort of subset subdomains of big
data around sensor data streams of data
that we're going to have to think about
new architectures and new designs for a
new technologies for capturing them
storing them processing them aggregating
them analyzing them and so on so I think
it's going to be a real interesting
evolution to see how the Big Data
technologies and technologies in general
are emerging to deal with streams of of
sensor data